so today my little sister eva is going  to be ranking my instagram picture okay  so what do you think of this one out of  ten yeah  five what why five it's kind of blurry  and out of focus what the  okay okay what about this one this was  in a bathroom yeah i know where that is  you took me there okay so yay nay um  four red's not your color  we're too pale for red  okay selfie  i'll say six  okay what about this one  four  why your meal is half eaten well cause i  was hungry okay but that's not the point  of instagram  okay what about this one  why  the booth isn't like clean and you're  wearing black on black the black and  black is skinny  not like that  okay what about this one ellie's in it  yay this one  six seasons